a new study shows that one in five
sun-like stars in this galaxy are
surrounded by planets that could meet
some of the basic prerequisites for life
like we have here the study was tough
published in the Journal of proceedings
of the national academy of science and
is based on a three-year examination of
data from NASA's Kepler space telescope
the findings were that scientists
calculated that 22% of stars are just
like our Sun and have planets similar to
Earth with a margin of error of plus or
minus 8% so that that's kind of that's
kind of big but that's still big number
we're talking about there are about 200
billion stars in our galaxy with about
40 to 50 billion of them like our Sun
meaning there would be at least eight
point eight planets like ours that are
probably inhabitable and have some sort
of life and if they've got some water
and some air maybe they have intelligent
life even though we don't have any here
are their space creatures out there I
love the idea of it and I know some
astrophysicists are probably gonna get
me on this one but I love the idea that
maybe some of these planets are like
parallel universes where a lot of us
exist on all of these different planets
just in different time periods with
different decisions that mean thing to
think about and there are so many people
who already believe that they have seen
aliens or seen UFOs or seen life from
from other planets and this is just kind
of giving them some hey yeah it's
possible yeah do we have any reason not
to think there's life anywhere else I
know people don't want it religion
doesn't want you to believe that but
it's see when you look at something like
this you know our star our Sun is just
like a very simple star it's nothing
great and they're showing you that
there's tons of others out there can you
imagine the Twitter followers you would
have if we can you imagine how many more
people are watching the Rubin report I
mean granted they they speak in clicks
but they'll be watching you for other
galaxies yeah just in terms of numbers
you know I think that Beth is right I do
think that maybe that this whole you
know the our whole Milky Way could just
be like a mirror image of another galaxy
I mean how do I know we're not just
looking into some crazy funhouse mirror
so we're looking into this Kepler by the
way this Kepler guy back what
what a sack on this guy naming all the
planets that he found Kepler 69 can't
bleed I mean it's like come on do ya can
you name them something else yeah
they're not gonna be happy about Kepler
when they find out that their planet
whatever they named it we're 42f yeah
yeah because of Twitter because yeah
yeah they'll be pissed but I think what
if it's just a big funhouse mirror and
we're just looking at ourselves did I
just blow your mother the funhouse
mirror thing yeah I get that I think
that is kind of possible but I think
might be a little more possible would be
that there's all these planets that are
at different stages of evolution right
because there's just different some of
them are gonna be less advanced than us
because life start because maybe the
planets a little closer to the Sun so
for some reason they advanced a little
slower
actually you're us yeah earlier us I
totally have to send a message it's a
seventh grade me yeah I don't know if
you're listening Kepler 47 but that is
not his brother all right
I'm sorry she'll know what I mean it was
it was a school dance
yes story should we be putting more
research into this kind of stuff do you
think I think I mean this is a it's a
fantastic it's a fantastic field and now
we have the technology on this planet to
actually send up telescopes that we can
see far off in into other galaxies why
not put more research into it because
you never know what we can find although
we don't want it to turn into you know a
place where we're going to another
planet to mine for resources the avatar
or what if we are really in like horton
hears a who right like what if we are it
like we think that we're so smart but
really there's a whole nother planet
that's watching us and like taking care
of us or a whole other galaxy rather
yeah they're taking care of us that's
like the episode of The Simpsons with
Lisa's little tooth that's right
civilization yes one of my favorites
can we trust our government to do this
properly if we would ever make contact
or contact was made with us can we trust
the people that are in charge not to
screw it up or is there any I mean it
seems to me we're gonna meet aliens one
day and either they're gonna kill us or
we're gonna kill them I don't see any
way really where we don't some whoever
more advanced doesn't end up destroying
colonizing the Avatar Theory I think we
send government to talk to him we send
comedians yeah interesting we have the
first conversations with you know actual
people that don't talk in sound bites
you really have actual conversations
loosen them up a little bit and then
maybe the relationships can start with a
bigger that's one comedian on the panel
like I just said and then we give them
the blankets with syphilis yeah here you
go we wrap that one up unless you have
any other thoughts I mean I would love
it I don't think in our lifetime though
unfortunately I mean unless our lifetime
is actually also happening in a
perpendicular galaxy right now happen
with that the electric currents that you
create through thought drops I don't
know if it'll be our generation but I
think our kids kids kids generations